- Alright, Biz Dev Sunday.
Just got my fresh cut.
Jordan just had a
good seminar. Proud of him.
We'll get into it in a second.
("Unstoppable" by This Is Wolff)
First item for Biz Dev Sunday is
the fact that you probably
saw VaynerSports sign
Braxton Miller, this coming up
weekend Jaylen Reeves-Maybin,
Jon Toth will be
finding new cities
so if you're a brand or a
milkshake, a restaurant chain,
headphones, any kind of
brand that's looking for
product placement
in social or creative
from football players,
Braxton obviously Ohio
is the king of that,
Texas where he plays with
the Houston Texans.
Jaylen in Tennessee,
Jon in Kentucky
and now their new
cities next weekend.
If you're a brand that wants to
do really interesting creative
with NFL players,
please hit me up
Biz Dev Sunday
email we'll get to you.
We're doing a ton of
stuff with these guys.
New creative stuff, you
might've saw a new DailyVee
a week ago,
we're excited about it.
Hold on, we're just
talking about when I beat
Jordan and Mike in basketball.
(Jordan laughs)
Last summer. That feels good.
Sorry Mike Vicante.
Anyway, what else do
I want to talk about?
VaynerBeta, Gabe Anderson
running a department
in our office that is really
exploding at VaynerMedia.
We were not working with small
and medium sized businesses
for the last two or three years
but now we finally figured
out how to have a product
that's about $35,000 a month.
$25,000 in fee for
strategy, creative, account.
All the creative, video,
pictures that are put out
and $10,000 in ads so
if you're a small or
medium sized business,
35K a month finally being able
to work with VaynerMedia
after being the kinds of brands
that had to spend millions
to be with us has been exciting.
Now we've been able to
do it for a couple months
I feel confident in
saying it to my community.
So, that's another
biz dev opportunity
if you're a service or
provider for small businesses,
for social or
things of that nature
hitting us up for that
but way more importantly,
if you want to be one of those
first clients in that system,
hit us up.
On that same note, Vayner
Experience is a new division.
We're doing activations,
lighting up brand
activations at Coachella,
the Kentucky Derby,
Super Bowl, CES, Cannes,
things of that nature.
So if you are
an event organizer
and want to do
more things with brands,
if you want to work
with Vayner Experiences
as us being the
exclusive provider for
sponsorship or create
events at your conference,
hit us up or if you're a
brand that wants to activate
at these big
conferences, hit us up.
Vayner Experiences
to the email down below.
Another thing that
I want to focus on is
Instagram Q&amp;As.
Gonna start making a video a day
where you guys ask questions
and for 30 seconds in
video form on your Instagram,
then I'm gonna
take that video chop it,
and answer it in 30 seconds
and make a one minute
video post on my Instagram.
So if you want to be in the Q&amp;A
put #AskGaryVeeIG hashtag.
Put it up here
somewhere in your post
and I'll pick one a day and
answer them on my Instagram.
Also, we're looking
for music for DailyVee so
if you've got a friend,
or if you are
rolling with the music,
send it our way down below.
Hope you guys have a great week.
Great Monday.